I have two children and I sort of like
the idea that they maybe don't go into
show business did you worry about your
kids getting into show business or
getting involved in show business
they're you know my what my son Oliver
is a senior associate producer of NBC
Sports but the others one's a therapist
and ones in wealth management and none
of them want to go to show and I pushed
them I wanted them to go into show
business you know I was you know they
would I make them do laps in the morning
and I kind of go to the balcony like
coffee anything arms a bunch of wieners
now throw them away nothing more
rewarding you know this that - there's
nothing more mourning as a father than
getting a deep tissue massage what are
the corner of your icing one of your
kids getting tutored in math I think
[Laughter]
connection with you're killed yes you
must be sensitive to your children's
needs and make sure your personal
assistant fulfills them there's nothing
I wouldn't throw money at for my kids I
want them to be tough and grow up and
that's why I didn't give them any
vaccinations or any of that vaccinations
oh please and weaken them
what a [ __ ] would not give a child a
Backson I don't know I don't know but we
have a lot of people watching so
whatever choice you make that's yours do
you feel instinctively that the bulk of
your audience is made up of non backside
looked into it yeah
ninety percent of our viewing audience
have been vaccinated yeah yeah oh so
much that we already knew yes